little ironic has written a book yes
[Applause]
under your seat I already on top before
we talk about it I'm going to say
because it's true it is a really funny
book I say that because it may not be
initially a parent when you start
talking about what it's about
yes pre-empting my poor salesmanship
because I tend to put people off
anything that's to do with me well
you're very kind to say that it is very
funny but now you need to tell people
what it's about okay and let me do some
damage now so it is about a Gwyneth
Paltrow films called view from the top
I'm in which she plays the stupidest
this is the post room you seen this film
is it's a real film I saw yeah yeah yes
it's a real film well baccala do I need
to see it literally you do not need to
if you've seen any film you have seen
this film it is very similar to all film
plays a blue-collar worker I don't know
what research she did maybe into Whole
Foods Juana she dreams of becoming an
air stewardess she becomes one that's
the film dilemma can she be an air
stewardess and maintain a loving
relationship with Mark Ruffalo oh yeah
no being an air stewardess a two ownerís
she's got to hand out salty nuts
this'll blow ething she's got to
demonstrate it's a nightmare
what should she do you're literally the
opposite of on the edge of your seats
stop telling me the story
she manages to reconcile with Mark
Ruffalo there's quite the salty notes
[Applause]
and at the end it is a huge gun battle
ends down and kisses him but this is
essentially a sort of academic reading
of it as if it's a classic I yes I saw
this film with my wife that's not a joke
that is possible that someone would
choose that and I was so haunted by this
film but it's taken me three years to
exercise my system and I've gone through
the book in forensic detail explaining
why it's so important and I've in to
open it with things from my life it
really is so important
to give this film the respect it
deserves
haven't seen it people aren't discussing
it can you believe this is the first
book about this film we need to have a
conversation about this film you do you
do we've in other things there's a
beautiful vocation of your childhood
Christmases in Ipswich yes and they
celebrate Christmas in it which to this
day my mother liked the house very clean
for Christmas we would have to clean
everything before presents were given
out which was on Christmas Eve my mother
was Norwegian
but it really was a ruse just to really
amp up the housework she baked a lot of
biscuits Christmas biscuits which I
found out aren't a thing I need cookies
you're on my turf now John
[Applause]
because we put out we put out biscuits
for Santa Claus okay I needed the
biscuits to have the energy to clean the
house does Gwyneth know about this yeah
she's not emailed me as yet I don't know
she may be you know in the middle of a
cleanse
[Applause]
[Music]
you